for the majority of human history the
snake has been associated with evil and
corruption but have scientists now found
an ally in the fight against coronavirus
in the most unlikely of places could
viper venom hold the key to destroying
covert 19.
according to a groundbreaking study into
the venom of a brazilian pit viper
scientists now believe it could this
highly venomous snake could hold a key
to fighting the virus that causes covet
at least that's the hope of these
researchers in brazil
researchers in brazil have found that a
molecule in the venom of a viper
inhibited coronavirus reproduction in
monkey cells by up to 75 percent
the snake in question is the dreaded
botherops girarokusu
a highly venomous species of viper
native to brazil and other parts of
south america the black and
yellow-scaled snake grows up to seven
and a half feet in length and utilizes
the deadly venom which is capable of
killing up to 16 people at once
when this predator attacks its victims
are overcome with shock internal
bleeding necrosis and liver failure ouch
raphael guido a professor at the
university of sao paulo and author of
the study said
we were able to show this component of
snake venom was able to inhibit a very
important protein from the virus
the molecule in question is something
known as a peptide
these connect to an enzyme of the
coronavirus called pl pro which is vital
to the reproduction of the virus
already known for its antibacterial
qualities the peptide can be synthesized
in laboratories making the capture or
raising of the snakes unnecessary
researchers will next evaluate the
efficiency of different doses of the
molecule and whether it is able to
prevent the fire from entering cells in
the first place
they hope to test the substance in human
cells soon but given no time scale
so it looks like the snake could be set
for the greatest public relations
turnaround of all time